[Music]
glen keane and Kobe Bryant okay we're
gonna start in the back with a t1 and
then they're gonna come up to 210 Kobe
hello look at the number
if you honest allegations allegations
you okay after winning five NBA
championship
now hold an Oscar how do you feel um
it's uh it's it's I feel better than
winning a championship to be honest with
you I swear I do it's it's you know
growing up as a kid I dreamt of winning
championships you know and it working
really hard to make that dream come true
but then like to have something like
this seemingly come out of left field
you know like I heard a lot of people
tell me when I started writing and it
would ask me what are you gonna do when
you retire and I'd say well I want to be
a writer one of your storytellers I got
a lot of yeah that's cute that's cute
you'll be depressed when your careers
over and you're come back to playing you
know I got that a lot and so to be here
right now and they have like a like a
sense of validation is this is this is
crazy yeah it's crazy not only that
after after the win you don't have to
sit in a tub of ice I don't we're coming
here two to ten and then we'll go to 28
hey Kobe Bryant congratulations and we
actually met at the White House opening
of the African American Museum yeah you
were telling me about this career Tufts
was about how different a skill it is
what's harder about it what's easier
about it
and what have you learned and what's
next well I think the hardest part about
playing basketball the hardest thing to
do is to get out of the way of yourself
I try to disassociate you know any sense
of ego that you have to be able to
perform and in writing it feels like you
have to get in in a deeper connection
with yourself and better understand the
fears and insecurities and things that
may be going on below the surface it's
not an attorney you can better
communicate those and so those are
really the
two major distinctions between playing
and writing or creating what more more
John John John Williams it sounds crazy
but he didn't say that but after you
scored the film he looked at being clean
goes okay that was way too short you got
to give me something longer I was like
oh we're trying we're going to 28 and
then we'll go to number seven I could be
Steve Buckman from a stranger yeah I've
seen you obviously you've won
championships Olympic gold medals now
this I want to know you talked about
this meaning more to you but at the same
time can you talk about the struggles
that you may understand now about
someone who's achieved fame and trying
to find a new outlet for their talents
and obviously you feel you've found
something here would you like to make a
feature film one day yeah we've actually
been hard at work over the last two
years focusing on novels and we've been
able to create five novels each novel
going out a series of five books and we
look forward to bringing that to the
market within the next couple years but
you know the hardest thing for for
athletes to do is when you start over
you really have to quiet the ego and
you'd have to you have to begin again
you have to be a learner all over again
you have to learn the basics of things
you know that that's really the hardest
part so my advice to athletes is the
first and foremost find the thing that
you love to do and I wake up in the
morning I can't wait to write I can't
wait to get to the studio you know so
when you find a thing that you love to
do then everything else tends to make
sense we're going to seven and they'll
come down here to 276 Kobe
congratulations Steve Gregory with iCard
KL AC I wouldn't ask you about how much
of this project puts you out of your
comfort zone
and what was like working with John
Williams um all of it put me out of my
comfort zone my daughter gave me the
best piece of advice I was a little
worried about turning us into a filmer
I've never done that something like that
before and we're in a house and we were
talking about as a family and my little
eleven your Gianna goes well dad you
always tell us to go after our dreams so
man up she's 11
man oh so I had to man up and go for it
and then working with John was
incredible you know John speaks about
music as if they're the each Key has its
own soul and it was amazing to sit with
John in the sit with Glen throughout
this entire process and hear the same
attention to detail that we each half of
our craft craft it's just it's just an
amazing experience to be able to to work
which I I can't even think the guys like
he's a real-life obi-wan Kenobi to me
yeah John had written his score yeah
he's 85 years old and wrote the whole
thing out by hand in pencil just like
the film itself has been pencil is it
he's a old school craftsman and with 80
instruments he wrote that and the day
that we were recording it he was like
this little kid just so energetic
charged know what is going on with
Johnny gave me a hug almost knocked me
over I was like damn I gotta be retired
but I'm tired that long it was not me
over and he stood up in front of the
orchestra and Coby and I sat there i as
someone realized he's never heard the
music
he's just been hearing it in his head
and he wrote it with 80 instruments and
recording it and he lifted his arms and
it was this beautiful score the score
that you hear and Kobe Kobe wanted to
shout and we know the red light and when
it was done John turns to us and says I
promise you it's going to get better I
said man we're done I thought we were
done over giant John was incredible yeah
276 then back to 24 lemagas goes down
the wall New York Amsterdam news down
the Utapau
I saw this at the Tribeca
wonders you got one or Whoopi Goldberg
shorts it was impressive and amazing
congratulations thank you very welcome
now a lot of people talk about their
heroes but I have a question for you can
you share the Shiro's in your life oh
yeah that's you know when I had the idea
of starting a studio the I like cold
calling people and so the first person I
called was Oprah and I I didn't
understand the business at all as you
can imagine but I like I loved writing
so I went to build a studio so I called
Oprah and she was very gracious enough
to spend about an hour and some change
on the phone with me walking me through
every step of the way of how she built
Harpo from day one and I cannot thank
her enough for that she was a mentor
then a mentor now Shonda Rhimes is
absolutely amazing and I was chopping up
the doors for me to go down to
shondaland and sit in the creative room
writers room and be on set and so when
you have mentors like that in your life
you know it's everything tends to work
itself out you just continue to learn
from the best of the best of the best so
those are my those are two yeah yeah
don't shoot the messenger I have been
given the wrap-up so 24 is the last
person 24 Wow big win for me that's
awesome Kobe dance fans against oh radio
you referenced to shut up and ripple
comments in your acceptance speech why
did you do that and what do you think of
LeBrons approach to handling politics
and discussing that which is so
different from your hero Michael Jordan
French well I think everybody must
approach things as if you know from from
their position of whatever is
comfortable to you know for them I think
for us not just as athletes but as just
people in general we have the ability to
speak up for what it is that we believe
in whether you're a professional athlete
or not whether you're an actor or not
you still have the ability to speak up
what it is that you believe in and and
as well as people have the right to
criticize this this is this is a
democracy that we live in that's what
makes America beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]